it's easy to forget now but Winters was
not seen by many as a comedy guy in the
early 2000s his best known roles at the
time were Oz and Law and Order SVU 30
Rock transformed his career and in the
years since Winters has fully given
credit to the show's Creator Tina Fay he
told backstage magazine in 2021 Tina's
in my top two favorite people in
Hollywood she's always been in my corner
what was originally meant to be a three
episode Arc in the first season became a
recurring role as beeper King Dennis
Duffy appeared in each of the shows
seven seasons in 2019 they reunited for
a pair of allate ads promoting the
insurance company's DriveWise app and
Winters has made guest appearances in
the Fay produce comedies girls 5 Eva and
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt he said of his
friend I'll do anything for Tina just to
be part of a Tina fate production she
knows the quality is going to be good
the actors are going to be good
everything is going to be good